[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Shaun, hi, GDG
is a very interesting
developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions--
JJ BEHRENS: This JJ Behrens
along with Jarek Wilkiewicz.
And we have two guests today,
Kieran Farr and
Jiang Li from VidCaster.
And this is YouTube
Developers Live.
Jarek, how are you
doing today?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Doing good.
How are you?
JJ BEHRENS: Pretty good.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So you've
been quite busy lately.
I haven't seen you around.
What have you been up to, JJ?
JJ BEHRENS: Well, I was
talking to my wife.
And she says, you're not
a real developer.
You just play one on TV.
And so I figured I should
do something about that.
And so I started releasing the
backlog of Open Source
projects that I have.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
So tell me more.
What have you released lately?
JJ BEHRENS: So I released
three projects.
The first one I worked with
Jeffrey Posnick on.
And it's called Party
Playlist Picker.
It's a Google App engine
application written in Python
that allows you to
collaboratively edit a playlist.
So it's pretty neat.
You have a bunch of people.
They're going to
go to a party.
And they're logged in on
separate computers.
And they're editing the
same play list.
And you can see updates in real
time from each of them.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
Did you use client libraries
or straight through
[INAUDIBLE]
JJ BEHRENS: I did.
I used Python Client Library,
which is unfortunately still
using version one of the API.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Old school.
JJ BEHRENS: It'd be nice
to update that.
And so the next one I built
a PHP project called
[INAUDIBLE].
And it takes a lot of
concentration to even
pronounce that.
It is not the best name
in the world.
It is just a proof of concept of
how to use PHP, OAuth2, the
newest client library from the
newer Google APIs along with
CodeIgniter and the YouTube
CodeIgniter client library.
And so the way I came up with
the name is I took all of
those words.
And then I just randomly pulled
letters, and shoved
them together, and threw
in a few vowels.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Wow.
So let's see, Python, PHP.
So what will be your next
programming language that
you're going to write in.
JJ BEHRENS: So the next project
that we released is
Quizzimoto.
Of course, we had a tutorial
about that before Google I/O.
And that's written
in Ruby on Rails.
And then finally, we have a
project that I haven't yet
released, but I'm going to
release, built in Android
using the new YouTube player
API for Android.
And I'm excited about that.
We announced that at Google I/O.
And I'm hoping to release
that code as soon as I can.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
So it sounds like every week,
you use a different
programming language?
JJ BEHRENS: Well, yeah, I didn't
mention the other one
that was written in Dart.
But I'm a Dart guy.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Oh wow, let's
see, there are 52 weeks
in the year.
Are there enough programming
languages for you?
Or are you going to have
to repeat yourself, JJ?
JJ BEHRENS: Well, actually
Haskell takes two weeks
because I have to
work up to it.
Haskell's not so easy.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Oh I see.
What about Lisp.
There's a lot of parenthesis,
so maybe
that'll take even longer.
JJ BEHRENS: Lisp works for
me or at least Scheme.
JUANG LI: Got an SDK or API
for Scheme or LISP?
JJ BEHRENS: No, but if you're
a Lisp programmer, you don't
need a client library.
That's just the way they role.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: We'll accept
change requests.
So if you're willing to submit
something else, then this is
Open Source library.
JJ BEHRENS: I keep joking about
the fact that the only
reason why we can't get a
COBOL client library is
because we can't find
an intern who
could code in COBOL.
And I refuse to code in COBOL.
I just have my limits.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: We'll
fix that, JJ.
JJ BEHRENS: Maybe next time.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Wow, so that's
pretty exciting, JJ.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah,
it's pretty fun.
So I'm kind of sad that Jeffrey
Posnick couldn't make
it here today.
Why couldn't he make it?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So apparently,
the cold season
has officially started already
on the East Coast.
JJ BEHRENS: I thought the people
at Google were like
immune to viruses.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Well, they're
immune to computer
viruses apparently but
not real viruses.
JJ BEHRENS: Oh, I see.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, so we
have lost Jeff for this week.
He'll be back next week.
And this is when we're going
to discuss the very
interesting issue
a API quotas.
So for those of you that are
expecting this coverage today,
unfortunately we have
to disappoint you.
A virus got in the way.
I know Jeff is watching
us this morning.
So hi, Jeff.
JJ BEHRENS: Is he still
answering email?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Probably
predicting what people are
going to ask, answering them
proactively next to a box of
Kleenex, I suppose.
So we'll cover that next week.
Instead, we'll chat a little
bit about our brand new
branding guidelines.
So we have a bunch of resources
for developers that
would like to use our branding
in their applications.
And this question comes up
every once in awhile.
So now I think we have a much
better set of tools and
guidelines.
But first, I think we'll talk
to our guests here.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, tell
us about VidCaster.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Right,
so maybe we'll
start with you, Kieran.
Kieran is the founder and
CEO of VidCaster.
And I have a tricky question
for you to start.
KIERAN FARR: Go for it.
Yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So I read in
New York Times that you have
actually bootstrapped the
company while driving a cab in
San Francisco.
KIERAN FARR: That's correct.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Is that true?
KIERAN FARR: That's
absolutely true.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So what
kind of driver are you?
Are you a laid back cab driver,
or are you one of
those fast--
KIERAN FARR: It's funny because
when I first started
driving taxi, my girlfriend at
the time, she told me Kieran,
you drive way too slow.
You're too good of a driver.
You should not be
a taxi driver.
And over the three years of
bootstrapping the company and
driving a taxi, I eventually
got to the point-- and I'm
sure Jiang can testify here--
where I drive like a madman.
So there's something in the
occupation itself that
inspires you to adapt these
driving habits that aren't
necessarily the safest.
JJ BEHRENS: San Francisco is
the only place in the world
that I've ever been where I've
gotten Oracle DBA advice from
my cab driver.
KIERAN FARR: That's
pretty remarkable.
The sort of characters that you
see driving taxis in San
Francisco can be very wide.
JJ BEHRENS: Apparently.
KIERAN FARR: But it was
a good experience.
And that's probably a
good segue to how
we started the company.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah,
tell me more.
KIERAN FARR: Yeah, so we
actually started VidCaster as
a completely different
project.
And I think this is the sort
of theme that you see a
lot in start ups.
And around 2008, we wanted to
create a local TV station.
And we actually partnered with
the San Francisco Chronicle,
other top blogs, such as the
SFist and SF Appeal, other
local TV stations,
like Coffee TV.
And we brought in a consortium
of students who are recent
graduates of videography
programs at different
universities.
And essentially, we partnered
with the traditional reporters
of these outlets to create
video content with them.
And so as we did this, we
realized that most of the
problems with our workflow were
not around the production
of the content.
I have a lot of experience
producing local TV.
I knew how to make that
a templatized process.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: How so?
Did you do that in school?
Or where did you pick that up?
KIERAN FARR: Actually, as young
as middle school, I
started doing live
TV broadcast.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
From your house?
KIERAN FARR: From our
middle school.
We did the announcements
in the morning
at our middle school.
And in high school, we had a
nice TV studio where we did a
live sports show
every morning.
We had one of the best
basketball teams in the state.
So there was a lot
to report on.
So anyway, I had all this
production experience and I
said, well, we can make
our own TV station.
I think that local TV in
America, especially, has a lot
of problems.
It's just all about violence,
and politics, and this
investigation about why Lysol is
going to kill your children
tonight at 11.
And I thought there's a better
way we could do this.
So anyway, so we had a great
process for creating content.
But it was much more difficult
to then streamline this
process to make it easy for
these reporters and producers,
who have limited time, to be
able to upload this content,
have-- what was most important
at the time was a destination
video site, in other words,
to have a location
where viewers can go.
This property was called
vidsf.com.
And this is the concept that
we like to call video site.
In other words, it's a website
around which all of the
content is oriented
around video.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Like YouTube.
KIERAN FARR: Like YouTube.
YouTube, of course,
is a good example.
But if we kind of look a little
bit wider, Netflix is a
video site.
That concept is something
that exists already.
And a lot of humans, viewers,
don't necessarily categorize
it in their brain.
But when we look at what these
elements are, at the end of
the day, they're templatizable
structures
that are video sites.
So you have an index
page where you
have featured content.
You have playback pages where
you play back the video.
You have, for example, episode
or show landing pages, where
it organizes all that content.
Anyway getting back to the story
here, we had to create
all of this infrastructure
from scratch.
And we tried calling up some of
the paid OVPs at the time.
These are Brightcove, Viala,
some of the larger names.
And we said, here's what
we want to do.
Can you help us with this?
And they said to us, well,
we'll give you a
video player object.
But you guys are responsible
for the rest of the show.
Well, the rest of the show is
the meat of this technical
development.
And so we just started writing
our own solutions.
After about a year, this brings
us to around 2010, we
had so much interest in the
actual software tools that we
had written that it was clear to
us that we would be able to
make a much better business by
selling this software instead
of trying to continue to
create this content.
So that was around 2010.
And that's what led the initial
developments of VidCaster.
And we got our first beta
clients, which was Airbnb and
Indiana University.
And we helped build that
out with them.
And then that eventually brought
us to the point where
we were able to join an
accelerator, called 500 Start
Ups, that really started the
development of this as a
company around the
software as well.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: What was
your number in 500?
KIERAN FARR: What
number were we?
I would just guess like maybe
160 or something like this.
I know they're getting
close to--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK,
is that [INAUDIBLE]?
KIERAN FARR: Hopefully.
That was a good experience
as well.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So you've been
working on the product
for a couple of years now.
KIERAN FARR: Now comes to about
four and 1/2 years.
I was driving a taxi all
the way through a
year and 1/2 ago.
And once we were able to join
500 Start Ups, they gave a
little bit of investment, which
was enough to get me
outside of the taxi.
And really then, that
was the beginning of
building a true company.
In other words, Jiang joined our
company at the same time.
We are very technology
focused.
So as you can tell by the way
I described this, we were
really trying to solve all these
technology problems.
And what we learned in the
real world of startups is
that, you can build
a great product.
And you can solve all
these problems.
And they'll show you all the
cool things that we do.
But the next step as a company
is sales and marketing and
creating a repeatable sales
process around this product.
And that's, what I joke, is my
MBA trial by fire that I
received over the past year and
1/2 of running a company.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Right.
But you had some experience
dealing with cash, and doing
basic accounting, and
things like that--
KIERAN FARR: Yeah, I think
I had a little bit of
experience.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: --in your
Crown Vic or whatever it was
you were driving?
KIERAN FARR: Good question.
So the cool part is that I
worked for a taxi company that
had tons of hybrids
on the fleet.
So I got to drive everything
from, of course, the Toyota
Prius to Nissan Altima hybrid,
all sorts of fun stuff.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great.
So how about a little demo.
And then maybe we'll talk about
some of the technical
challenges.
I know JJ is dying to ask Jiang
some tricky questions.
KIERAN FARR: Yeah, so I'll
turn the computer
over here to Jiang.
While Jiang is working on this,
I'll give a little bit
of a description of kind of what
we're looking at here.
So what this is VidCaster
powered by YouTube.
At its core, what VidCaster
lets you do is
create a video site.
So what Jiang is doing here is
logging in and granting access
through OAuth, and I'm sure
that JJ will have some
questions about how we
implemented this.
Now what it's doing is actually
connecting to YouTube.
And it's retrieving a list
of that video content.
And what we do at VidCaster is
abstract that metadata into a
unified format.
And what we'll talk about in a
second is that this allows us
to work with any number of third
party video platforms.
Of course, YouTube is
one of the most
popular ones on the planet.
So that's one of the
first ones that we
started to work with.
And so what this will do then
is create, for example,
thumbnails, total running time,
all the sorts of video
related metadata that you
would want when you're
organizing a video site.
And we try to do this as
quickly as possible.
And Jiang can talk at length
about how we've been
optimizing our process
for this.
And so then what this brings you
to, this is what we call
our onboarding process.
And this is a live preview
of what your videos
site would look like.
And now we have close to a
dozen designers themes.
We work with designers on a
regular basis, creating more
and more of these.
In fact, we'll talk a little
bit later about we have a
whole templating language around
VidCaster very similar
to a Wordpress but made
specifically for multimedia.
And we're actually holding a
theming contest that we'll
start in a few weeks with some
cash prizes to get developers
to join the fun here.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So the use
case here is say, I am a bed
and breakfast.
And I want to have an awesome
site because I am right on the
beach, and I have beautiful
bedrooms.
So I will basically do what?
KIERAN FARR: So then you could,
if you have existing
videos in your YouTube account,
you can instantly
start this process, choose
a theme that's from our
pre-built theme garden, and then
customize that logo, and
choose a URL.
And there's two different ways
that people use this.
They either use it one, as their
entire website or two,
they use this what we call a
video sub site, very similar
in spirit to a blog-- how a blog
lives in a sub domain.
We suggest to our users to use
either TV, .domainname.com, or
video.domainname.com.
And this is a practice that
we've been seeing--
not just VidCaster pushing for
this but companies like Adobe,
for example, have really used
video on a branded sub site.
So TV.adobe.com is
a great example.
And they put literally dozens
of hours of content.
A lot of it is around support,
how to use their products.
And this serves both as
marketing and sales material
but, of course, also support and
training material, which
both really kind of serve
the same purpose.
And I think at the end of the
day they're trying to get more
people to use Adobe.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool
So I interrupted
your demo flow here.
Apologies for that.
Let's go ahead and continue.
KIERAN FARR: Yeah, so
then this dumps you
out into our dashboard.
And this dashboard again is
meant to abstract, regardless
of the video player system
you're using, to have a
unified set of analytics,
content management control,
and we've been doing
implementations lately that
combine as many as
five different
online video platforms.
And I can show you an example
in a few minutes.
We worked on a project with
MIT where we combined the
YouTube player with Brightcove's
player, and
Kaltura's player, and the Vimeo
player, and our own
white label player into one
cohesive interface for both
their content managers but then
also for their viewers so
that they don't have to worry
about the complexities of
these different APIs.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Do you find
that this is a pretty common
use case where people have
content all over the place?
KIERAN FARR: Yeah.
This is something we're finding
more and more with
larger companies.
And to be clear, anybody can
sign up for a VidCaster
account for free.
Our free plan is powered
by the YouTube player.
And then for larger companies
with more complex needs,
that's when we help them--
because we have all these
integrations already existing.
And it helps them get to market
very quickly with
whatever solution they're
looking for.
And what we find typically is
that companies all around the
planet have videos all
over the place, but
they don't know it.
So a really common problem is
that let's say, the tech team
put up a bunch of tutorial
videos, and they
really liked Vimeo.
Their marketing team put up a
bunch of videos up on YouTube
on the YouTube channel.
Other folks took videos
at a party.
They put it up on Facebook.
This other department has a
contract, let's say the
internal training department,
has a contract with Kaltura
because they've been good about
marketing about education.
And then, at the end of the day
you have this nightmare
from a management perspective
of what do you do with all
these assets?
And are these assets actually
driving business or
accomplishing the objectives
that we have, whether it's
reducing support queries,
whether it's increasing our
number of leads, increasing
revenue?
And the reality is that
nobody knows.
And this is something that
almost every single
organization has this problem.
And when we look at how do we
solve this problem, it's not
about a video player.
The video player is part
of this problem.
But that is kind of one
of these tools.
And really it's about collecting
all the stuff into
one solution to then, at the
end of the day, give
management the sense of yes,
these videos across our
YouTube channel, on Facebook,
and on Vimeo are indeed
driving people to have this
behavior, or this post viewing
behavior, that we value.
And that's what we believe is
what we call closing that loop
and finally helping companies
realize that what we believed
all this time is that video has
a huge amount of value for
the enterprise.
But it's hard to
quantify that.
And it's often very difficult
for them and the accounting
team to say, it's worth it for
us to be spending all this
money on producing
tutorial videos.
It's worth it for us to be
producing this sales and
marketing material and customer
testimonials.
But connecting those dots has
been a very big challenge.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Speaking
of which, can they track
conversion?
Like say, I go to one of these
video sites, and watch the
video, and click on a buy now
link or something like that.
Is that reflected in
your analytics?
Like how do they actually know
that what you just said is
actually true that they should
invest in content.
KIERAN FARR: When we work with
our larger clients, what we'll
do is we'll usually interface
with their customer
relationship management
software or CRM.
So common ones, of course, are
Sales Force or Marketo.
There's--
I'm trying to think of
a couple other ones--
HubSpot is another common one.
And a lot of what this is really
turning viewers into
leads and tracking OK, once that
viewer has supplied their
email address, then how do they
fall into that funnel?
So that's where our philosophy
is that we don't want to build
every single tool.
And we try to combine all these
things together into one
easy package.
And that's kind of our eco.
So then we'll leverage the Sales
Force, or the Marketo,
or Hub Spot installation that
enterprise has to do that
reporting and analytics.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So finally,
a very tricky question.
So do you think that video
improves the conversion?
KIERAN FARR: Hmmm.
I have to think about this.
Well, the obvious
answer is yes.
If we want to be kind of high
level hippie about this, video
is moving pictures.
And it's one of the most
effective mediums that humans
have invented.
And it's undeniable that
it's a powerful medium.
And I think that what's really
been missing is connecting the
loop or closing the loop.
And finally, we're going to
the point where we can see
that, and we can actually
quantify that.
And that's what gets us really
excited because we can finally
say, hey this is working.
And even if it's small percents
in the single digits
of traffic that's coming through
their main property,
that traffic still converts
at a very high level.
It's very relevant.
If you're looking for tutorial
videos on how to use an arcane
server product, there's a very
high chance that you're going
to want to purchase
that product.
So I think what we're really
seeing now is finally, after
all this time, the data and
evidence that's supporting our
intuition that we've had
for a long time.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So shall
we look under the hood?
KIERAN FARR: Yeah.
JJ BEHRENS: Sure.
Well, first of all you were
talking about some of the
companies that you've
integrated with.
And I know some people out there
might not know the video
landscape as well
as you guys do.
So can you tell us all the
companies you've integrated
with, and what each
of those companies
provides for the users?
KIERAN FARR: Yeah, I don't know
if we'll have time to go
over all of them.
But I can give you a sense
of the big categories.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, categories
would be fantastic.
KIERAN FARR: So one of the main
categories is what we
call the player object.
And this kind of goes back to
my belief that a player
object, whether we're talking
about the YouTube player.
That's what I would define
as a player object
or other third parties.
And there's now on the market
I'd say roughly 60 to 100
different player only video
platforms out there.
And what they usually provide
is a white label, brandable,
video player object.
And so we've done integrations
now, I'd say, with about 10
total of these.
And that number keeps
growing as we do
more and more projects.
So that's one category.
Another big category would be
third party social network
distributions.
So this is taking this content
and then pushing it out to the
common folks you hear about,
Facebook, Twitter, other third
party platforms like that.
Analytics is another really
big category.
Of course, there's the standard
players in there like
Google Analytics or Omniture.
What we're seeing more and
more is, like I mentioned
before, analytics plug-ins that
have a relation to the
customer relationship
database.
So this is Sales Force,
Hub Spot, et cetera.
And we see things like Mix
Panel, or Kiss Metrics, or
other sort of third party
tracking systems that our
clients are using.
And then there's this really new
category of what I would
call interactivity layers
on top of video.
And there's a number of
startups around this.
I'd say there's at least a
dozen, or two dozen, startups
that have varying types of
interactive video technology.
And for our customers, it's
exciting to be able to have
all these different options to
be able to say OK, I want to
be able to click on this dress
and buy this dress, or I want
to be able to have social
comments in the timeline and
link out to that.
So we've done a couple
integrations on that end.
It's a little bit difficult to
be honest because there are so
many startups out there
that are doing this.
It's hard to find a standard.
And we've been looking at
there for a standard.
I know that Mozilla is working
with Popcorn.js is one sort of
standard that's kind of somewhat
seeming to gain
traction in the sense that
it's timeline based
interactivity for generic
player objects.
Another category we've been
doing integrations with is
open source video players.
So we've had an integration
with the
JWPlayer for quite a while.
We've been working with the
team over at Video JS.
That's been an interesting
player because it actually
supports, for example,
YouTube is a playback
layer beneath it.
That's also very interesting
because VidCaster, at that
point, serves as this cloud
based player that has an
updating open source player.
And then our customers can
choose to use their own CDN.
So that would be another
category where a lot of our
customers will have existing
CDN relationships.
They'll want to plug-in, for
example, they have existing
contract with Akamai.
Or they have literally a server
on Premise that they
want to serve this
video content.
So then we connect all these
dots and help them connect all
these things together
in one place.
JJ BEHRENS: That's really
interesting that you're
serving video from so many
places, including the big guys
as well as local.
So integrating all of those
is kind of interesting.
So my favorite question is what
did you guys write it in?
JIANG LI: We wrote everything
in Django.
JJ BEHRENS: Django, wow.
Crazy.
KIERAN FARR: Yeah, we've enjoyed
Python and Django as a
great framework and language
combination.
I started writing, of course,
this code back in 2008 when I
was driving the taxi.
We have a joke around the
office that is taxi code
because it was very utilitarian
and functioned.
But now poor Jiang and the
rest of the dev team are
dealing with that technical debt
and bringing that code
base up to speed.
So for example, I know you're
going to ask some questions
about our API integrations.
And this is something I did
like two years ago, for
example, for our initial
YouTube integrations.
And it's definitely time
for an update.
I want to say that we were
using, for example, in the
Python library side, it
was a 1.0 library.
But we were kind of hacking it
to access some 2.0 features
because not all of them were
built into that class,
necessarily.
But you could still
kind of access it.
JJ BEHRENS: Thankfully, that
situation's going to get a lot
better with version 3 of the API
with completely up to date
client libraries.
Life is going to
be much better.
KIERAN FARR: Yeah, that'll
be really helpful.
JJ BEHRENS: But I
feel your pain.
JIANG LI: Another problem we
had was we tried to get all
that viewership data from
YouTube, and one of the big
things is the viewership.
So we had to use the insight API
and download a lot of zip
files [INAUDIBLE] client.
And that generally
takes a while.
So when I heard about the
new analytics API,
I was pretty excited.
JJ BEHRENS: That's going to
solve a big pain point.
Now, I'm really hung up on
this idea of you writing
Python while driving a cab and
the fact that you said your
cab driving skills were
originally very orthodox and
then went towards the sloppy.
And I'm thinking of Python
indentation.
I'm just imagining at the
beginning of the project,
everything was force
base indents.
And then towards the end of the
project, it's like three
space indents. and two
space indents.
KIERAN FARR: It's funny
you mentioned that.
That is something that Jiang has
brought up as we need to
go back to the code base and
make sure that we have unified
indentation.
JIANG LI: And especially when
people start using tabs.
And you're just like
what's a tab.
JJ BEHRENS: That's
pretty funny.
So do you guys have
plans to switch to
version 3 of the API?
Have you thought about it?
I mean of course, we have to
wait for it to fully come out,
but will you guys make the
switch to save a lot of pain?
KIERAN FARR: Definitely
on the analytics side.
We're getting close now to about
7,000 video sites that
are powered by YouTube.
And for each of those sites, you
can imagine that there's a
lot of synchronization that
happens on a regular basis.
So one of those synchronizations
is, of
course, analytics data.
Another important
synchronization is, of course,
based around the
actual content.
Has somebody uploaded
new content?
And what I can show you here is
a demo of how some of our
customers use this.
And maybe that'll be helpful.
In fact, if we can
switch to this.
This is a great example of how
one of our customers, who was
also one of our investors, 500
Startups, integrates VidCaster
into their website.
So this is their main
website at 500.co.
And when you click on the video
tab, this actually leads
to a website that is hosted
by the VidCaster system.
So it's really important to
understand that part of
VidCaster's value is actually
hosting the website itself
that has all this video
content embedded.
Now all of the stuff, of course,
matches the branding
of the main site.
The only reason you know it's
another server is it's on a
sub-domain, which
we've see named.
And then, this provides all of
the navigation elements,
things, inconveniences, such as
most viewed this week, all
sorts of preview things.
And what I'd like to do now
is kind of show you--
we'll press play.
And you can look at one
of these play pages.
These are all customizable.
I'm going to pause this
for a second.
And so you can customize
everything here.
For example, you can work with
all sorts of third party
commenting systems.
This is another category
to add to that list.
So there's Facebook comments,
LiveWire comments, Discuss.
Exactly.
JJ BEHRENS: Another Django
app by the way.
KIERAN FARR: Yeah, exactly.
Our friends over there
at Discuss.
So I wanted to show you is
how they made this site.
And so what they did is it they
started with a very basic
layout, the basic rotater.
And we have close now to about
a dozen different themes.
A lot of them are
mobile friendly.
They uploaded a logo, they
uploaded a fabric con, did a
little bit of CSS.
But one of the most powerful
things that we're excited to
show off is what we
call custom HTML.
And what this is the ability
that within the cloud, we have
a cloud based code editor to
actually edit the templates
for these themes.
And this is where you get very
powerful customization.
And what we built this on is on
top of the Django built in
templating system, we've
introduced a series of
convenience functions for
dealing specifically with
multimedia content.
So one of the best examples
I'd like to show is, for
example, this function right
here, fetch thumbnail URL for
a given object, which is in
this case, a lead item.
And you can specify the width
and height of that image.
The reason why this starts to
become so powerful is that you
can imagine if you're a larger
company, and you have five
different video players systems,
each one of those
actually has a completely
different API
for fetching a thumbnail.
And as small as this task
sounds, when that creative
agency is trying to create this
site that combines all
these things together, just that
one function of getting
these preview images turns out
to be a big pain in the butt.
So this starts to put that layer
of abstraction on top of
this CMS made specifically for
video content so that this is
an easily repeated automatable
process for the organization.
JJ BEHRENS: Great.
So you guys host
videos as well?
KIERAN FARR: We do.
So we have what we
call our white
label, cloud based player.
Now this is an interesting--
if we want to get into a little
bit about the world of
online video, my core belief,
frankly, is that video objects
are turning into a commodity.
There are some that have great
infrastructure behind them.
And I think YouTube
specifically, obviously, has a
great CDN infrastructure.
JJ BEHRENS: We have
a couple servers.
Two or three.
KIERAN FARR: And when you start
talking about the video
objects ecosystem, really all
that you're talking about now
is the latency of play
to first byte.
Everything else is easily
repeatable, whether we're
talking about the Chrome
controls over this plug-ins
for advertising.
So anyway, I interrupted you.
JJ BEHRENS: So you
have white label.
So that makes a lot of sense.
So one of the things about
using web API that can
sometimes be challenging
is doing testing.
And so a lot of people decide
not to do testing.
What approach did
you guys take?
JIANG LI: So we basically have
many servers that we do
developing on.
It's actually station servers.
So our developers have their
own developer server.
Then, we put everything
into a staging server.
We have basic tests that we
run on the staging server.
We do pushes every Thursday.
JJ BEHRENS: Every Thursday.
The day after YouTube.
KIERAN FARR: Yeah.
Well essentially, this way, when
we're developing, we're
actually developing in that
same server environments
because like you're saying, we
do interact with so many third
party services.
And then, when we push things
to staging, that's an exact
replica of our production
environment.
So we can see everything from
how do the load balancers
affect forwarding of IP
addresses for our analytic
system or whatever.
JJ BEHRENS: Great.
So can you tell us anything kind
of interesting looking
back now that you've
spent so much time
developing this software?
What are the things that
kind of surprised you?
What are the things that you
wish you could tell yourself
and go back in time?
By the way, we have a project
x project for that, maybe.
KIERAN FARR: I would say one
of the things that's very
surprising to me is not
necessarily about the
technology but about running a
company and having a software
product and that is that the
things that customers find
most valuable, sometimes have
no correlation with the
difficulty of programming it.
So for example, very complicated
syncing technology
in the back end that we have for
all the third party OBPs.
That's cool and that's
necessary.
That's something that takes
some time to sell that.
However, this sort of technology
that we've made for
letting people edit the template
structure, that
didn't take us a huge amount of
time to develop compared to
the syncing technology.
But this is something that
people really value.
And it's surprising to see that
just because you slave
away at this one thing or this
feature, it's not necessarily
that's going to be what
brings you forward.
And for me, it's been a humbling
experience over the
past year to realize that we
really need to have an ongoing
dialogue with our user base
to understand what is most
valuable to them.
JJ BEHRENS: That's that age old
thing where nondevelopers
only care about the things
that they could see.
If they can't see it,
then they just
don't care that much.
KIERAN FARR: And things like
having these custom themes for
people to be able to choose from
existing themes, that's
been really, really popular.
And again, that's not
necessarily a coding thing.
We're not sitting in the
basement writing all this
awesome new stuff.
That's working with awesome
designers and contractors from
around the globe creating
cool stuff.
Excellent.
So Jarek--
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I have one
more question for these guys
before we let them
off the hook.
What you have been
showing is web.
Now what about the brave
new world of mobile?
What do you see your customers
doing in that space.
KIERAN FARR: Great question.
So we have a couple different
ways that customers use us
with their mobile
applications.
Probably the best way that we're
moving toward it is that
everything we do is HTML5
responsive design.
So about half of our themes now
are true responsive design
where it actually can change the
look, and feel, and layout
of that themes as it's used
on different devices.
And then we also have basic
API that works across
different players as well that
allows our clients to create
mobile applications that will
pull from this API and,
depending upon the player, then
can use, for example, the
YouTube SDK, and an iOS app,
or HLS if they want to be
delivering stuff directly from
one of their servers.
Another really exciting thing
we've been working on now is
in partnership with the Google
TV team, we're working on a
couple apps for clients
using the new
YouTube SDK for Android.
So we're excited to
get a couple of
those off the ground.
And those should be coming out
in the next few weeks.
And that's been an exciting
process because we're seeing a
lot higher adoption of users
by Google TV because it's
actually being embedded into new
televisions that are being
released by manufacturers.
So instead of having this extra
box, it's something this
is literally built
into the TV.
And at that point, everything's
ready to go.
And you just navigate your
remote to these apps.
And it's pretty exciting.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Cool.
Great.
Nice that you're
covering that.
JJ BEHRENS: So I love this kind
of squirrelly question.
And it's a little bit strange.
But you guys think about
video a lot, right?
Like this is your life.
So what do you think we're going
to see two years from
now, 10 years from now,
and 50 years from now?
KIERAN FARR: Well, I'm not sure
if we're all going to be
humans 50 years from
now, so maybe we'll
leave that one out.
But I think what's really
interesting coming
down the line are--
JJ BEHRENS: That's not
funny at Google.
We get enough Borg
jokes as it is.
KIERAN FARR: I think that, for
example, the whole concepts of
Google Glass and heads up
mounted displays really
continued to accelerate
the adoption of video.
So for example, having cues
that I know that at this
intersection when I'm walking
down the street that this can
trigger a couple options for me
to see anything from well,
here's the cool place to
go for a cup of coffee.
And because recording a video
is so easy now on all of our
mobile devices, this is
becoming so pervasive.
So I think that the new mobile
in a few years will actually
be how do we interact with that
is our heads up displays.
And that's again just
accelerating
this growth of video.
It's not just incrementally.
Like that's just a
whole new area.
JJ BEHRENS: Excellent.
So Jarek, I'm peeking
over at your laptop.
It looks like we have
a lot of questions
lined up in the moderator.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: We have
quite a few questions.
But maybe first we will chat
briefly about some of the new
branding resources we
have made available.
JJ BEHRENS: Oh, I'm sorry.
Yes, let's talk branding.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Let
me just cover that.
So for those of you that care,
we have been providing,
powered by YouTube, logos that
can be embedded in your
applications.
Now the resources that we have
in place were created
several years ago.
So that was really before
the explosion of mobile.
On the previous page, we're
actually showing how to best
integrate the YouTube logo
into a DVD player.
So that was kind of state
of the art at the time.
I'm sure you guys have or used
to have one of those.
So the world has changed
significantly.
So what we've done is we have
revamped the branding
resources so that if you are a
mobile application developer,
we actually have YouTube
branding that you can use in
your mobile application.
We also made it a little more
clear about when you can use
which logo because that wasn't
really well covered in the
previous version of
the document.
So maybe let's switch to the
page that has these resources,
and I will just quickly
walk you through it.
And again, if you have any
questions about this, feel
free to ping us or ask it
on the developer forum.
But what we have made available
is a set of
guidelines that help you
identify first of all which
logo you can use.
And there's actually two
different ones that we are
making available, the powered by
YouTube logo and the actual
YouTube logo.
The way to understand the
difference when you can use
one versus the other is very
similar to what we have
previously captured in our
monetization guide.
So if your application is
actually built entirely around
YouTube and really relies on
the YouTube content to the
point where if you remove
the YouTube content, the
application is no longer useful,
then we would like you
to use the powered
by YouTube logo.
If YouTube is one of the
features of your application,
so you're integrating YouTube
content, but you're adding
additional content, additional
data sources, and so forth.
So if you remove the YouTube
functionality, the app is
still largely functional, then
you can use the standard
YouTube logo.
And we have a couple
of examples.
For example, let's say you were
a game developer, and
you're integrating YouTube
apples capability.
If you take it away, we would
obviously be sad.
But the apples continue
working.
And the gamers will continue
playing games.
So it's OK in that case to use
the standard YouTube logo.
We do have a couple of
things that we would
like you to not do.
For example, build an app that
is just like YouTube and it
doesn't really add any
additional functionality.
And then, on top of that, we
discourage you from actually
calling it YouTube because
then it will
just lead to confusion.
So there are some of these
things that I think are very
straightforward, written
in plain language.
So hopefully, you'll be able
to go through this and
understand.
And then the part that we also
made a little more easy is if
you are actually looking
for the assets,
they are right here.
So we have the EPS AI files
that you can download and
scale to fit your application
needs.
Another type of logo that we
also are providing is the
stock logo.
So this is something that our
mobile developers have been
asking for quite awhile saying,
hey I'm building a
mobile application.
The horizontal layout is really
not doing it for me
because of my user experience.
So while we prefer that you use
the standard YouTube logo
because this is what the users
are familiar with, we are also
making the stack YouTube
logo available for you.
And you can fetch that
from the site.
So the URL is, as you can
see, developersgoogle
.com/YouTube/branding.
YouTube And if you have any
questions about these
guidelines, please
let us know.
JJ BEHRENS: Great.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
And now we have received
a bunch of questions.
So perhaps we should just switch
over to the moderator
and cover some of them.
The first one is around
applications availability.
When will we have annotations
available for mobile?
So no ETA right now.
I think obviously mobile
is a big focus.
And I wasn't able to ping our
product manager who is
actually flying in from
London this week.
If you would like to learn more
about what's the vision
for YouTube mobile, I would like
to encourage you to watch
our presentation from Google
I/O, where Andre who is our
product manager actually
covered his
goals for this year.
And the title of the session
is [INAUDIBLE]
API for Content Curators,
Creators, and Consumers.
So you can look it up.
And we will chat with him to see
if this is something that
they have any plans for.
Typically, we don't actually
announce specific dates before
functionality becomes
available.
But obviously mobile is
a big focus for us.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah it's a shame
that you weren't able to get
an answer to that because I
noticed that you were able to
email the PM during the talk
while we were focused in on
the screen.
It wasn't for lack of trying.
I know that it was only the
PM that doesn't respond as
quickly as you do.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: There is no
YouTube Live Developers show
without JJ making a joke
about me emailing.
That's a [INAUDIBLE].
The second question we had was
around availability of some of
the YouTube features that we
make available for partners.
So for example, the YouTube live
streaming, which is what
we're using right now, it's
currently not available for
everyone on YouTube.
So if you're a YouTube partner,
you can actually have
access to this functionality.
It's not rolled out to all the
partners as far as I know.
So there are some restrictions,
some geographic
considerations, and so forth.
So the way to approach that if
you are a YouTube partner,
just chat with your
partner manager.
So typically, partners have
a resource that is made
available for them for any kind
of partner questions.
And they should be able to
give you better guideline
about what is available,
or when it might become
available, or what needs to
happen for you to actually
have access to this
functionality.
In the meantime, you're
welcome to
use Hangouts on Air.
This is something that uses the
YouTube live streaming.
Infrastructure for the
live streaming
part works quite well.
So beyond that, I think we can
probably defer you to your
department manager.
JJ BEHRENS: And of course,
Google plus Hangouts have an
API, which is really exciting.
So you could do all kinds
of interesting things.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: The next
question is will we see an IOS
YouTube apps suit.
JJ BEHRENS: Ooh, ooh.
I want to answer this one.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, so what
I did this morning is I
was basically running around
trying to find somebody who
would ask this question.
And everybody basically
refused to talk to me.
So I couldn't get a straight
answer out of anyone.
However, I did find one person--
his name is Matt--
and he works on YouTube PR.
And he told me that-- and he was
keeping a straight face--
we are working with Apple to
offer the best possible
YouTube IOS experience.
JJ BEHRENS: 100% true.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So this is as
far as I was able to get.
So what do you think, JJ?
Did I do well, or is
it disappointing.
JJ BEHRENS: That is
100% the truth.
JJ BEHRENS: All right.
So unfortunately, that's
all we can cover today.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, sorry
about that.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Then there's a
question about video ratings
where someone can dislike a
video but like is not working
using the API.
What we would like this is maybe
some ideally some log in
information if you could just
post it on our forum.
It's strange.
I don't think we are preventing
liking videos.
JJ BEHRENS: It might be
interesting to see the HTTP
response coming back from the
servers to figure out what's
going on there.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Although we
just released a downer video
feature, and you can
only dislike it.
You can't like it.
JJ BEHRENS: The world is
becoming more cynical on a
daily basis.
KIERAN FARR: It's a feature,
not a bug.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So please let
us know, give us a little
more information.
Ideally the video ID, we can
try it ourselves and see if
this is a bug or if there
something with the request
that is not quite right.
There was a question about
that PlayStation
implementation.
Can we add Like and Dislike
button on the YouTube
PlayStation app?
JJ BEHRENS: Can you get that
done before lunch, please?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah.
So we just launched that
yesterday, I think.
So it's nice that folks
are paying attention.
I have actually passed that
feedback to our product
manager for the PlayStation
app.
She has actually posted the
announcement on the
PlayStation site yesterday
and actually
showed it on my G+ stream.
So we'll definitely relay it.
And if we have an update,
we'll cover that.
JJ BEHRENS: Thanks for
the suggestion.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And then there
was a question about the
ability to add more than
19 playlists on the
main channel page.
JJ BEHRENS: This is because
we're using newer machine
architectures that are,
what is it, five bit?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: So that's
a good answer.
OK, next question.
JJ BEHRENS: We're sorry
about that.
What's our real answer?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Again, I
wasn't able to get an answer
out of our product manager who's
responsible for that.
I'm not sure if this is a user
experience design limitation
or just we thought that no one
would actually want to have
more than this many playlists.
Although even that actually
playlists have limited sizes.
I think we're still up
to only 200 entries.
Then, it kind of makes sense for
channels that have a lot
of content.
We'll check that.
JJ BEHRENS: I definitely saw you
send an email to the PM.
So hopefully, that's
good feedback.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Another
question is when would we be
able to pin channels on the
new YouTube mobile app?
So if by pinning you mean the
same thing that is actually
available in Google Play, this
is something that to a certain
extent is available today.
It's not offline viewing.
But you can, in fact, configure
your app to protect
some of your subscriptions.
There are some conditions.
I believe that the phone
has to be on wi-fi.
And you have to have your
power plugged in.
The use case here is at night,
your phone synchronizes the
information that is needed
so that during your daily
commute, you can just play it
right off your SD disk.
Again, this is something that
Andre covered during our
Google I/O sessions.
JJ BEHRENS: I seem to remember
this during the keynote maybe.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: It was
mentioned during the keynote.
And then, Andre actually went
into a little more detail
during our presentation.
So I'll post that.
As far as complete offline
access, I'm not
aware of any plans.
I think it would be rather
difficult to even implement
that because of some
of the ways in
which our player works.
The next question is you could
see a live video on the
cellphone Android.
I think if this is a question,
the way I understand this is
whether this is actually
possible.
And the new YouTube Android
player API that we had
preannounced at Google I/O,
actually has this capability.
So if you were at Google I/O
and you actually downloaded
the Google I/O app to watch any
of the live streams, we
were in fact using the
YouTube player API.
So this is a little known
secret that the app
itslef was using it.
It was a very early version.
But we were actually
using that API.
So we are actually hoping
that this is something
that will be supported.
There are some restrictions
around which versions actually
have the capability.
So I don't think it's going to
go back as far as the kind of
core version of the library.
But the capability should be
there when we release.
Let's see.
JJ BEHRENS: So we had
some more questions
kind of scoot in.
And we also had another page
full, four more on the next
page or something.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK,
so we covered the--
let's see.
Let's just go over
to the next page.
When will YouTube have high
quality content videos?
Now many contain low
quality content.
YouTube now mainly can see
low quality content.
So actually the way this works
is quite interesting.
A lot of people don't
necessarily realize it.
So when we integrate--
when you upload your content
to YouTube, we actually ask
you to upload as high
resolution as
you possibly can.
In fact, we support
4K right now.
This is something that is not
quite there in your living
room probably.
But when it comes,
we'll be ready.
On top of that, we actually
have search parameters.
So this is where if you're an
API user and so you only want
to have HD content in your
application, there's actually
a search parameter that narrows
down the list of
content to HD only.
So if you don't like some of the
old [INAUDIBLE] of videos
that we have on YouTube, and
our know our PR is going to
kill me for that.
JJ BEHRENS: Why you got
to be like that?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Because
YouTube is more than
[INAUDIBLE] videos.
So if you want to restrict the
search results in your
application, you can
probably do that.
And then again, if you upload
content produced content, we
actually like high resolution.
And we'll transcode it down to
resolutions that work on
various devices, mobile devices
for example, when you
guys are ready to pursue all the
different mobile platforms
out there, we'll make sure
that it works correctly.
But historically, not
all content was HD.
YouTube has been around
for while.
But definitely, you can restrict
the search results
using the API to HD
content only.
And then you will live
in an HD world.
You will never see a
[INAUDIBLE] video.
JJ BEHRENS: I was a little bit
lost about this question
because there's actually like
three things going on.
There's one, do we show
high quality videos
in the YouTube player?
And the answer is,
of course, yes.
The second thing is does the
API return videos that are
high quality?
References to [INAUDIBLE]
answer is yes.
And the third is do we allow
raw access to the
high quality videos.
And the answer is no because our
content partners wouldn't
like that so much.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, as far
as the video playback, this is
something that comes up every
once in a while when folks
want to, say, force HD for
whatever reason on an embed
that is of a small size where
it doesn't really
make a lot of sense.
So this is where we--
and I guess two player actually
we used to support an
HD param which would
attempt to play HD.
And now, what we are actually
doing is something that is
slightly different where we
would like to be intelligent
about the play back and make the
best determination based
on the number of factors.
If you really feel like you have
to have HD, and you don't
actually have an embed that
has the height of 720p, so
actually one video of HD.
But if you really have
to do that, you can
still use the API.
So you can actually set this to
just a play back quality.
And this is something that we
support in our iFrame API,
which by the way is now
the supported API
for the YouTube player.
You can actually set it and
try to overwrite it there.
Yeah, so that's a
good question.
Any other questions, JJ,
that we should cover?
JJ BEHRENS: I'm looking.
Here's one that looks like--
oh, geez.
It just disappeared--
the link object of the movies
feed in the YouTube API
contains invalid links.
And it looks like some PHP--
so there's entries,
sub zero link self
leads to a 404 error.
Is there something
I'm missing?
Anyway, great API.
I love the second half
of that sentence.
I'm a total sucker
for flattery.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yeah, I think
it would be great to get
some more info on the forum,
ideally maybe the response,
the video ID.
That always helps us so that
we can try to debug it.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, definitely the
video ID and posting it to
our forum, we could probably
debug that.
JJ, I have a question.
And I forgot to add it
to the moderator.
And my question is--
you ready?
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: You
really ready?
OK, the question is YouTube
Developer Relations hiring?
JJ BEHRENS: That's
a great question.
And the answer is
absolutely yes.
So yes, YouTube Developer
Relations is hiring.
And so if you're as good looking
and fast with email as
Jarek is, we'll--
or maybe even if you're not as
good at email as Jarek is,
we're definitely interested
in talking with you.
In fact, Developer Relations
across all
of Google is hiring.
And we're also hiring software
engineers like crazy.
Send me email directly.
We get referrals, bonuses
and stuff.
But yes.
And I would say that of all the
15 billion startups I've
worked for--
Google's not a startup--
but Google's the best company
I've ever worked for.
So I like it here.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ:
Good answer, JJ.
Thank you.
JJ BEHRENS: Thanks.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
I think we are out of time.
So we'll probably wrap
it up for today.
JJ BEHRENS: VidCaster,
thank you guys for
coming, Kieran and Jiang.
KIERAN FARR: Thanks a lot.
JJ BEHRENS: It was awesome.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And we'll
see you next week.
JJ BEHRENS: Thanks
for coming, guys.
Yeah, we'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]